welcome to the White Lotus in Sicily
last season really got into privilege
and this season it's more of a kind of
bedroom farce with teeth
it's about how awkward we all are and
how sexual tension prevents us from
knowing each other and being able to
accept each other as a plot stream it's
about toxic masculinity and trying to
break the cycle everyone is functioning
in a way to manipulate or undercut
another character I'm not a fool stop
flirting with my wife some of the themes
are infidelity family bonding murder
it's kind of got everything
season two is decidedly sexier than
season one
also the environment lends itself to
that romantic summer Vibe I think Sicily
is the perfect place for romance and
sexual politics
so special it's an out of time place and
you feel like you're in this bubble
when we saw the Four Seasons in Taormina
it was just such a beautiful location
and it just sold this kind of old world
European summer vacation
[Music]
the first season we were lucky to work
with such an Eclectic range of actors I
really wanted to duplicate that again
this season anytime I shoot with
Jennifer Coolidge the hardest part is to
keep my concentration and not to laugh
it I sold a bug the great thing about
season two is Tanya really gets to come
out of her shell what if I take a look
in the mirror and then just like bite my
arm really hard
maybe not that
Mike White
he brings a positive energy to me Mike
he's a maestro he can make you laugh and
cry about life in the same time
I'm so impressed with how his scripts
spin so many plates he takes care of all
the different characters in The Ensemble
and weaves the stories together we're
all a protagonist to our own story and
antagonist to someone else Mike can
write characters that don't have a lot
of redeeming qualities and he gives them
a break
[Music]
it's a great company of people who like
each other and like what they're doing
and are proud of what they're doing you
Bonds on a set like this because there's
no way out the True Romance for me of
this production is just getting to have
this experience with people that would
end up becoming close friends and having
this intense collaborative experience